foreign
hey guys
welcome to another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
you guys having a good time dude I'm
having a good time man Here We Go
episode 276
uh and I will be in let's do the dates
here I will be in Peoria and Rockford
Illinois I got some Illinois dates
Illinois I'm coming to chibi Illinois
because there's an S at the end of it
but I'm doing Illinois I'm you know I'm
succumbing to the uh the pressure of
societal Norms uh we're gonna call it
Illinois but I will be there Friday and
Saturday get your tickets at
crystallia.com chrysalia.com and I will
be in Raleigh North Carolina I will be
in Savannah Georgia and I will be in
other places like Denver and Tempe
Arizona and Albany New York look at all
this [ __ ] look at them off the top of
the head Lakeland Florida look at this
Jacksonville Florida he's hitting
everywhere but um yeah and then I got
other dates coming uh pretty soon I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna you know I
shouldn't mention it yet but it's gonna
be New York and it's going to be Chicago
and it's going to be San Diego and it's
going to be Austin but I shouldn't
mention it
uh and it's all good dude and we say
it's all good because it's all good this
is episode 277 not 276 I think I said
two I whatever it's 277.
um yeah man so we're having a good time
go get your merch here Falls coming in
right we're gonna keep it cool life rips
got a [ __ ] staying on the end of that
that's cool but uh the Periwinkle puff
That's How We Do It
um and if you got a little bit more swag
which I don't
we wear bucket hats on life whips and I
don't I don't like I don't like bucket
hats but the fans have spoken they want
the bucket hat so we made the bucket so
what do you want from me dude hey what
do you want from me you know
um
yeah man I didn't talk about this last
time on my podcast which is um let me
drink some Lacroix respectfully but
disrespectly
um
yeah man I uh I did the Oakland shows
and I didn't even [ __ ] mention last
time a fan got stabbed
oh dude he got [ __ ] shanked it was
leaking ah
oh dude
someone [ __ ] summon the street and
poked them all up
oh [ __ ] man
someone [ __ ] poked them all up dude
what the [ __ ]
and then you [ __ ] tagged me on the
story because I checked my stories after
the show so I could [ __ ] do some
repostings and the guy's just like hey
bro I'm leaking man I'm leaking man
somebody [ __ ] cut him up real nice in
Oakland dude this is after I [ __ ] I
go if you watch my tour report on my
second Channel my crystal it's called
crystalline official on YouTube
um you just look it up it's Oakland tour
report Fang got [ __ ] poked up dude
and then posted about it on his story
hey bud go to the hospital but there's
[ __ ] images of him in a bloody shirt
he's like look man showing off how he
got all stabbed oh man I think he had a
[ __ ] cross tattoo on his chest people
with cross tattoos always be getting
stabbed you know that dude you know that
man my hair is [ __ ] absolutely on
fire right now dude Jesus Christ I
didn't realize that I didn't I didn't
[ __ ] wash my hair this morning and
now by the way I wash my hair a lot okay
everyone's always like you're greasy and
[ __ ] I'm not greasy dude you come near
me you smell me it's [ __ ] Off to the
Races dude you come here you smell me
you go like this oh [ __ ] I do meet and
greets some people smell [ __ ]
horrible some people smell real nice
dude and when they smell real nice I
tell them I'd appreciate it if you told
me because your boy smells like a
[ __ ] bed of flowers no dirt
like I just smell I mean I smell
incredible all right and my hair didn't
wash it today so I thought it was going
to look a little [ __ ] bad I looked it
in the mirror before the podcast I was
like eh I don't know but with the
headphones on absolutely let's put this
[ __ ] to bed my hair looks phenomenal man
so that's what's up man hair looking
great thank you very much and a fan was
stabbed
um can't believe that man Oakland and
[ __ ] Stockton you know we talked
about it last time but they are
absolutely uh it's it's wild dude it's
wild
um you know what's weird to me is
everything is being treated like cancel
culture no matter what it is like this
[ __ ] tour thing
how he to a magnan donovich or whatever
the [ __ ] Tua bogdanovic whatever the
[ __ ] his name is
got a concussion and then the doctor
like cleared him for the next game and
then
he [ __ ] got another concussion
and uh it sucks because when he went out
you know two concussion you get to get
two three concussions that's it that's
when the CT CTE is just like
and you're like who is it and they're
like oh he's gonna [ __ ] your life up a
little bit later okay we'll come back
okay
right you get one your body one
concussion they're like okay cool
but two concussions especially in a row
did you see two at the end like he was
[ __ ] [ __ ] walking dude he fell down
and he just [ __ ] it goes like this
said down hike boom
[Music]
who banging on the [ __ ] dude I mean too
it was just [ __ ] out dude throwing up
gang signs holy [ __ ] did you see the pig
put it up right here I mean that [ __ ]
looks different dude I mean his hands
were doing some unorthodox [ __ ] dude I
mean he got smacked and he was in a
[ __ ] football stadium but right then
he woke up and he thought he was
[Music]
wipe the dust off them [ __ ] Adidas
holy [ __ ] man
I'm that's [ __ ] up but though you see
those G-Force dudes those when you pass
out and you wake up and you just
you think those g-forces you know you
you think you're you're just all of a
sudden someone fought you out of
Vaughn's parking lot and you're just
like oh [ __ ] no I'm just never mind my
bad okay
I'm just trying to see how many forces I
can go and I got to G5 and then I passed
out and I'm just practicing for my
for my flight school
yeah dude you know you [ __ ] got
knocked the [ __ ] out when you wake up
and
[Music]
um
your hands your hands do crazy [ __ ] when
you get knocked off so he had two out
he got knocked out he got two
concussions and they fired the [ __ ]
doctor that told him it was okay to play
and that's cancel culture dude they
treat everything like cancel culture
it's insane
the doctors the doctor the doctor knows
the doctor sometimes makes mistakes by
the way the dot guess who would have got
fired if he didn't clear two of the play
doctor
it's all about money and somebody needed
to take the hit dude and the doctor was
like okay I'll clear it because I get it
this is football and you need to make
your bags and then when Tua got hit the
second time
[Music]
the doc goes like this oh no when Tua
woke up and just [ __ ] the
Transformers when two woke up and was
just banging on a Transformer as the
doctor goes like this I'll pack up
I'll pack up dude when the doctor
[ __ ] saw those the [ __ ] West Side
the doctor goes miles done he's like I'm
out bye-bye I get it I'll be the one
I'll take the hit cause somebody's got
to take the hit because cancer culture
hey how about just
look
look
let me just say this all right and it
seems
it seems totally Elementary all right
but football
is football
when football looks in the mirror it
sees football it's not something else
okay you take a picture of football and
then show football that picture Football
goes like this that's me all right so if
you're trying to turn football into
something else I.E something where guys
aren't going to be getting concussed
then it's not football
you take a picture of that football and
show the picture to football and
Football goes like this who's that
because it's not him
so if you're gonna be doing football
left football be football dude okay the
SEC this is the thing people are gonna
get concussed but they're grown-ups they
can do what they want now is it going to
be sad when they grow up and [ __ ]
and they get to be [ __ ] 60 years old
and they want to put a bullet in their
own heart so that you can study their BR
like whatever Junior say I did
hey study CTE and blast it away at his
own heart
yeah that's true that's troubling and
it's sad
but we all know we all know so football
is football so if it's gonna be football
then that's what's up dude
if not get rid of football stop with the
hole if we do this if we have these
rules if a guy can't play and then this
and this we need to look out for the
safety it's football
you might as well be baking a cake if
you're not going to let guys play
because of because they're gonna fall on
the ground and
[Music]
who banging on the transform you know
what I'm saying
it's football and then you're gonna be
mad when they fall on the ground and
they start asking who banging on the
Transformers
you just took a picture of football
developed it said that the football and
said who's that and Football goes like
this it's me
foreign
concussed that's what they should do
dude the Miami Dolphins should just come
out and be like you know what here's
what we're doing now they come out in
aprons and [ __ ] with like [ __ ] you
know dough rollers and just something
and other [ __ ] in it with
ingredients and [ __ ]
and there's already tables out there in
the 50-yard line and they just go like
this
hike and then start making a [ __ ]
cake and some muffins and then other
people at the fans like what are they
doing and they go sorry the culture came
for us and now we're not football
anymore
you're firing doctors out there you
would have been fired no matter what if
he didn't play the game the way the
[ __ ] Miami Dolphins wanted him to
play they would have got fired that way
they would have put another doctor and
he would have couldn't play he would
have got fired don't you understand how
this [ __ ] goes
football you're football
and that's the most crystalline [ __ ]
ever but it's true
he speaks the truth of Jesus Christ
uh uh he speaks the truth
but it's the truth
it's just like it's like enough is
enough dude oh but this is what the
doctor should have done oh really a guy
that [ __ ] you know what I mean works
as a realtor sometimes
oh really some [ __ ] chick you know
what I mean in uh
that sometimes goes to Armstrong Gardens
and raises some kids oh really
it's just so [ __ ] it's so ridiculous
dude
stop stop it you know what I mean that's
the thing you make you if you have the
game and all of a sudden you're like
whoops we need helmets then put the
helmets on and go to work okay
or or just stop the game right but this
whole well we gotta no stop bending you
already bent enough your football that's
the game dude
it's like it's a [ __ ] War but yeah
but okay but take the guns away and use
slingshots no you gotta [ __ ] push
people's wigs back dude that's the whole
[ __ ] thing you run out there the the
weapons get better and better you got
flame you got [ __ ] all the shits you
got bombs use them all that's War
imagine people it's pretty soon cancer
culture is going to start [ __ ]
bitching about you know well we need to
replace the guns with
War and I'm not even [ __ ] you know
what I mean you got me acting all
Republican and [ __ ]
I'm Centrist baby but don't push me
that's what I'm saying where's the Hat
I don't even have it anymore but don't
push me
um I don't know man I I don't know
look at the [ __ ] here's the
should I look at it the two of [ __ ]
the way he put his hands up
who bang it on the Transformer
who look at this
oh it's gonna be loud [ __ ] God damn it
here we go
boom
Oh wrong song dude Wrong song dude Wrong
song need needs it to be [ __ ]
go banging on a Transformers what is it
even mean dude dub she was the best
dubstee when he would do the [ __ ] where
he was like
like dude he talking about killing
[ __ ] and then just
who banging on the Transformers with the
[ __ ]
you know making his hands into a w w w
crystalia.com
um
so yeah between two are getting
concussed and my fans being stabbed not
a good not a good not a good week for
the Dolphins organizations and also
crystallia fans
um I can't wait till Tua comes back and
he's just like it's fine I'm fine I got
concussed I'm a grown man I want to play
football
it'd be amazing if they the whole thing
went all I don't know if he spoke yet
but if the whole thing because he didn't
speak for a while I know and the whole
[ __ ] organization's just like talking
and everyone's talking on Twitter and
[ __ ] and they're like well finally we
get to hear from Tua himself and they
just show him how to Podium and two is
just like this
[Music]
I'm like oh my god well too how do you
feel and he's just like
who banging on the Transformers
[Music]
don't push me over don't push me over
dude I don't even like football you got
me out here defending football
let's see what this is dude the right
stuff this is a [ __ ] dating app only
for today we brought it after you've
been pushed
all the way over to the right it's
called The Right Stuff dude it's a
dating app put dude
look at this [ __ ]
today we brought in a group of
conservative young women and wanted to
get their honest opinions about what
they're looking for oh my guys they date
hell yeah dude
what are you looking for in a partner it
would be great if they just went off you
have to be a conservative
wow dude the first thing dude they
[ __ ] jumped off the building with
that dude I mean they didn't even eek
into it they're like well I wanted to be
funny and nice I just wanted [ __ ] that
everyone says and loyal she just goes
first of all they have to be
conservative and the subtext was I don't
want a [ __ ] idiot
really someone that wants to have kids
that's a second independent man
personally I like the alpha male Vibe I
want a man who really loves his family
definitely someone whose faith is
important to them for me it's someone
who actually wants to meet my parents
hey why do you want to date a
conservative what is this for me at
least I know that we're gonna start off
with some shared values
for me what I do know is [ __ ] gay people
that's right here I'm just making a joke
well the conservative men I've dated at
least know how to treat me like a woman
in my personal experience conservative
guys have better manners I like that
they understand their role in the
relationship as a man so neighbor I just
prefer my men to be masculine yeah
and what's the biggest red flag when it
comes to amazing that this is already
the third question dude like dude that's
the third that's the third question dude
the chick wait okay so the chick who
said so that's the third question the
chick who said well first of all they
have to be conservative is going to
answer this question now let's see what
she says when it comes today a Democrat
wow she knows what she wants
and she knows what she wants
she knows what she wants and just how to
get it
wow dude she knows what she wants
she knows what she wants
she knows what she wants
she knows what she wants and just how to
get it dude unbelievable man
Democrats a Democrat can't be a Democrat
a Democrat that's easy a Democrat no
Democrats to know
download the right stuff today
oh my god dude
that's hilarious dude Jesus got the
music you know
I'd love to see the other version of
that dude just the [ __ ] left stuff
just like a [ __ ] people you can't
even tell if they're men or women and
[ __ ] hi I are you what do you want what
do you want what do you want in a
[ __ ] date what do you want in a
partner well they can be really whatever
man I don't care I have no preference
they just ask a chair next what do you
want what do you want and it's a chair
but then I'm just a chair but then up
but then um it's a puppet with blue hair
but don't put that off
let's ask Kent but don't put that off
it's a female puppet let's ask Kent but
don't put the hand off put that on so
just so well I definitely it doesn't
matter but I don't want her
I don't want a [ __ ] conservative but
damn um dude that woman and that's this
is hilarious dude
today we brought in a group of
conservative just [ __ ] the die
imagine the liberal version of this dude
they just ask a [ __ ] they cut to a an
empty bottle of Pepto-Bismol what do you
want in a [ __ ] mate and wanted to get
their honest opinions about what they're
looking for in the guys they date
what are you looking for in a partner
they just have to be a conservative dude
all right so here we go the right stuff
was created for conservatives to connect
in authentic and meaningful ways other
dating apps have gone woke we bring what
is by the way how does a dating app go
woke it's just you anyone can join right
it's like [ __ ]
isn't what isn't farmers only the one
that was supposed to be this but they
made it Farmers instead of whites
right
like that was founded by [ __ ] for
sure
I don't know I mean I know there's
[ __ ] I mean there's definitely
Mexican Farmers but like that'd be
hilarious if they try to get in there
and then the wife's like oh this is all
[ __ ] [ __ ] man [ __ ] man we forgot
there's a bunch of Mexican Farmers God
damn it man
um the right stuff was created for
conservatives to connect with authentic
and meaningful ways other dating apps
have gone woke we bring people together
with shared values and similar passions
dude anytime someone says shared values
that's so something that they [ __ ]
that's such a the way that [ __ ]
people have made that to be a trigger
for [ __ ] racist you know that's
hilarious discovering other
conservatives connects with people who
aren't offended by everything else
dude that's so good man oh [ __ ]
that's hilarious look Brittany 24 5 8 3
miles away
getting back to normal this is great nor
wow they don't even pull any punches
getting back to normal view profiles
without pronouns your next match is here
this is hilarious dude
this guy's a videographer Paul 29 three
miles away everyone's three miles away
uh less talking more dating have a fun
date idea post it and see who's
interested Luke 30.
have an extra ticket to Saturday night's
game who's looking to cheer on the home
team wow so [ __ ] General so General
invite only connect with people [ __ ] man
wow man
find the right match if you're single
then on this app you ain't can wait what
if you're single and not on this app you
ain't conservative well
ain't
gosh that's hilarious
oh my God that's amazing
get on that I want to know what that is
somebody send it to me somebody sent me
what their profile is on the right stuff
hey guys I want to take a break but I
want to do this to tell you about
something a little something called ship
station it's great do you have an
e-commerce business that ships products
out you need this don't wait until
you're drowning in orders to find the
right shipping solution upgrade to ship
station today the best time to prepare
for growth is before the opportunity
arrives and that's now okay especially
for online businesses ship station sets
you up for growth by directly
integrating with every shopping cart and
storefront I use it
um and we are ready for any anything
including the holidays with ship station
so uh whether you're starting small or
scaling up ship station makes ship
happen no more limiting your business to
for to one store ship station integrates
with every platform including Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify Etc dude they do it
all so you got to get ship station
maximize your sales you need to
maximizing your sales with minimal
effort then you got to use ship station
you save time with call uh consolidating
order management and automated shipping
updates for your customers they compare
carriers rates and delivery times and
you get the most out of every cent so
join over a hundred and thirty thousand
companies who have grown their
e-commerce businesses with ship station
98 of the companies you that use
shipstation
um for a year become customers for life
so come on guys get involved dude
here are some companies that use it
chubby shorts sock Club Spigen cases
conscious box Saddleback leather
Offerman wood shop uh daily look I mean
just the list goes on uh ship more and
grow more with ship station go to
shipstation.com today and sign up with
promo code congrats for a free 60-day
trial and that's what I use ship station
start today and get set up before the
biggest shipping season of the year
that's two months free visit
shipstation.com Click the microphone at
the top and type in code congrats
[Music]
uh today's national boyfriend day which
is cool
all the dudes get to find out what you
know it's so funny dude because all the
chicks with the [ __ ] thong ass
bikinis trying to like act like they're
not hookers and [ __ ] they're gonna be
all like you know today's the day
National boyfriend day and this is the
day they're gonna get the most unfollows
[ __ ] in cells at the Cure at the
keyboard going like this this is the
number one day the incels of the
keyboard go like this oh [ __ ] dude all
right unfollow
[ __ ] man I really had a chance
um
she gets National boyfriend day so
that's great man thank God live it up
for all the boyfriends out there man
um I just think that it's great living
of all the boyfriends
um
the [ __ ] fact that lizzo came out and
did the flute dude huh lizzo killed that
[ __ ] right
she would never be on the right stuff
here we go
wow is all
wow
hmm it's an interesting outfit for her
[Applause]
what'd you say
it doesn't matter what you said
oh it's a crystal flute
she's I don't mean
physically she's big like everyone loves
her
killed it
absolutely [ __ ] slaughtering it
wow that's a bad outfit for her
I'm on the right stuff though that's a
really bad outfit for her uh the first
only person to ever played the
presidential 200 year old flute
Christopher just 200
oh wow dude [ __ ] dude Thomas Jefferson
rolling over in his grave and then
wishing he could [ __ ] her dude for real
man wow Thomas just [ __ ] I'm telling
you right now the legit John Adams just
went like the [ __ ] corpse to John
Adams Even though it's just skeletons
they did that [ __ ] and John Adam goes
like this
foreign
oh dude
just [ __ ] just got me a piece of that
just got me dude that always makes me
laugh
oh dude the [ __ ] video of the guy who
got dude let's watch it again honestly I
know we've seen it on this podcast but
uh [ __ ] this man it's too funny man oh
piece of that yes got me dude that's so
uh funny man okay hold on uh QVC what is
it uh QVC
um uh samurai sword accident here we go
here we go I mean I love this [ __ ] wow
1101 1816 is the item number on this one
and the nice thing about these practice
guitarists
oh oh that hurt
oh that hurt big time
a piece of that just the tip just got me
Adele
oh that got me good you all right a
piece of that tip just got me you've
been so nervous
oh tried now
we uh this guy may need
a degree so drunk in the studio yeah
that guy for sure dead by now wow dude
just got me and the guy comes in oh we
might need a
emergency surgery the guy's dead for
sure died [ __ ] six years later in a
horrific car accident
like [ __ ]
like [ __ ] was on a bridge swerved
because a [ __ ] cat ran across
and then you're into the side of the
gate and the car was on teetering and he
was like oh I'll probably get out of
this one and then [ __ ] was there for
a legit 58 seconds and then fell to his
death and perished holy [ __ ] I love I
love thinking and making [ __ ] up [ __ ] it
man
wow dude
oh [ __ ] man
oh yeah we have a good time though man
we have a good time God damn I love this
podcast uh but yeah that's a bad outfit
for lizzo
um I watched the uh dude did you hear
about the [ __ ] fishing dude uh uh
that was winning a hundreds of thousands
of dollars in PRI prizes from fishing
competitions because he was sticking way
weights in the fish
like and you've been doing it for 10
years
and he's just been like taking weights
and stick him in the fish's mouths and
then they'd weigh the fishes and then
like now because of this guy they have
the [ __ ] guys who do the fishing
competitions take lie detector tests
afterwards
hey how about just don't do fishing
competitions
my fish is bigger okay
it's all lock
the guy's just [ __ ] dude he would
just put him in the put like one pound
weights in a [ __ ] trout
and won hundreds of that my whole thing
is bro that's not even that's gaming the
system yeah it's cheating but boy did he
game the system
That's crazy dude now just they caught
you next guy put them in the fish's anus
um
yeah that's so [ __ ] crazy it's crazy
to do something so
like is that I wonder if that's a league
It's gotta be illegal like to [ __ ]
you're stealing money right I mean it's
lying and stealing money wow
wow wow
um
yeah man
I [ __ ] it's a it is a crazy world out
there I wanna but by the way I should
have [ __ ] started this by thinking
about everybody in Florida people like
to say that you know they go on to be
thinking about everyone to go on a TBR
podcast thinking about everyone in
Florida that's how [ __ ] tough I know
actually some of the people on my
patreon they reached out we were talking
on the Discord they're in Florida and
they're doing okay but man it's crazy I
saw some of these [ __ ] things and
it's just like I mean some of these the
the streets are just I mean like up to
half the garage and people are just
it sucks man apparently a lot of people
died I haven't really been keeping up on
it um maybe I should but you know my
buddy's in Florida now I got a bunch of
buddies in Florida you know they're all
doing okay but
It's just tough man
ugh I feel like too some people aren't
leaving the way the times are I think
people are using like no we don't like
people in Florida they don't leave they
don't leave bro
they don't leave you could be like hey
we just found out that aliens are coming
down and all they're doing is
disintegrating houses in Jacksonville
so you should probably move and they go
people from the north of Florida are you
[ __ ] kidding me they would just be
like I spend too much time here to leave
for a little bit of a [ __ ] alien I
spent way too I grew up here it's my
home they all think that they're [ __ ]
Michael Kane in a movie you know they
all think that they're like some like
deep Matthew McConaughey character and
it's just like but just move for a
little bit
but hey dude
you want to die the way you want to die
you could you could do it I feel bad
though man I feel bad about this mother
nature that's a [ __ ] isn't it
um
oh God if Kristen watches another
[ __ ] serial killer documentary I'm
gonna just empty my bowels all over the
couch
it's just everything we you know it's
like either Dahmer or [ __ ] the other
day that that what was it the anthrax
one was on Netflix Netflix will just
make a [ __ ] document it doesn't
matter how then Anthrax one was big but
they'll be like they'll make one about
any it they made one about the Lori
valos or whatever the [ __ ] everyone
already knows all that [ __ ] you know
Dahmer I get it because there's like
there's like there's there's like the
biggest ones they'll always be made and
then like maybe one that you've never
heard of but Netflix will even make the
ones in the middle that we already know
all this [ __ ] about but then they'll
just like they'll make it like it's some
big Dahmer [ __ ] and it's not even a
Dahmer [ __ ] you know it's just kind of
sad man I was hearing What Lil Boosie
was saying about how like dude it's so
[ __ ] up for the families and [ __ ]
about the the the the
um
it's so [ __ ] up for the families of
the of the people who were slain
they say that to make it sound normal
more noble which is you know I guess
good because they were slain but
uh and it's so [ __ ] up for these like
imagine you you you're like husband or
wife was killed by some serial killer
and then and then they make a
documentary and a [ __ ]
you know a crazy uh uh series about it
that's like you know all for the dollar
and you just gotta sit there and watch
as people are like oh I'll buy the guy's
prison glasses for 150 000 because
serial killers are sexy you got [ __ ]
thoughts on Tick Tock just like these
are the these are the serial killers I
would [ __ ] in order and it's like yeah
but they [ __ ] kill people are so sad
it's kind of [ __ ] up there's nothing
to do about it but I mean like I feel
like Lil Boosie's right they should be
paid
these families should be paid to bring
up all their trauma and [ __ ] but I don't
know man
like at least with the Forensic Files
like they pay the people to come on the
show it's like they'll make 350 for
talking about it
and that was when I realized you know
the ice cubes had castor oil GT in it
and that was when she realized the ice
cubes had Castrol GT formula in it
um
but yeah we watched that Anthrax one
which was I didn't know am I racist I
thought it was the [ __ ] people from
uh Afghanistan or Saudi Arabia whatever
the [ __ ] it was I'm I'm dude I had no
idea that it was just some kooky white
guy
that was just literally Anthrax and
everyone tried to get involved the one
on Netflix is good it's got that dude
from the um that one Marvel show that
everyone I guess watches I don't know
what it is but he's a good actor
um
the guy who obviously was uh it was
between him and the guy who actually got
Better Call Saul
but then that guy got it
um
anyway he plays the guy and it was just
some guy who was like leading
investigators down a wrong path and then
it was really him mailing out all the
anthrax to everyone because he was just
he he felt like he had a Dark Passenger
inside of him and he was like I don't
even know what I'm doing but I'm mailing
all this Anthrax everywhere and then he
and then he um killed himself before
they even [ __ ] brought charges on him
so uh you know they never really proved
it was him or what because they never
took him to court but it sure looked
like it was him you know who knows and
then
um yeah he just [ __ ] killed himself
so we'll never know that is crazy man
and then how [ __ ] terrible the postal
service was where they'll just stay open
because all the employees were just like
they don't give a [ __ ] about them and
then and then they just the second
somebody mailed something to Dan Rather
they were like okay everybody out of the
building everyone out of the city it was
mailed to Dan Rather he's beloved
everyone out of the city and then the up
the Postal Service workers they were
like look we're gonna remain open just
be cool everything's fine dudes with
hazmat suits coming in
and everything's fine just make sure you
lick the envelopes if they aren't licked
if they're not closed lick the envelopes
yourselves
and then if people died
in DC dude
I don't know am I racist because I
thought it was a [ __ ] I don't know I
don't know man
uh
I was on stage the other night in Oxnard
it was awesome and all of a sudden dude
the lights were so bright
I just go like this oh huh I'm gonna
pass out they were so bright and I'm
talking doing my Act
you know people laughing people
listening and immediately just will go
like this oh
gonna pass out and was struggling so
hard for 10 minutes like don't pass out
you ever get that really don't pass out
and they're like well you won't but we
are thinking about it now so oh [ __ ]
maybe I'm gonna pass out no no no wait
hold on a second oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no
you got this just think about breathing
and then like hold on been thinking
about breathing too much whoa gonna pass
out bro I was [ __ ]
whoo
I didn't pass out but I don't know what
I never felt like that before I got off
stage I was so tired and then I drove
home and I drove home and of course was
weight was so awake and then [ __ ]
couldn't fall asleep yes
I feel like that right now because I'm
thinking about it oh my God
Masa amini the Iran woman killed because
she was wearing
um
everyone's talking about this to a
concussion and this Iranian woman the me
you know
the media I guess it is not covering her
enough but she uh was killed um
because she wasn't covering everything
but her eyes
we got to get the Middle East to
just kind of
let's catch up huh you know I get it
tradition and tradition always [ __ ]
leads to so much turmoil I've always
said that on this podcast right
I mean how mad just take how mad is a
dad when Thanksgiving isn't right you
know what I'm talking about so could you
imagine hundreds and thousands of years
of women's just dressing the [ __ ] up and
not showing anything but their eyes and
then all of a sudden
one woman just it slips a little bit and
then gets beaten to death like hey
that's
the strength of 10 million dads
with Thanksgiving not going right
and
that's horrible like let's just catch up
anybody who thinks oh
you sound so woke but like let let you
know I joke around about thoughts on
[ __ ] Tick Tock and [ __ ] Instagram
and it's but they can do what they want
all right
it's terrible that these [ __ ]
This Woman's getting I mean also the
amount of comments that I get on my
Instagram
be our voice of Iran it's like me
speak out please use your platform I'm
like me
but uh yeah it's obviously very terrible
and uh
I can't imagine being mad at somebody
else period you know live in the living
life not die
um
foreign
Drew Barrymore is uh is she uh you know
it's it's interesting to watch these
famous people uh go from
well let's just watch this
here we go here we go
eat the bread wow I want some pizza so
bad I'm sure people are gonna be like
dare you do this to a pizza I got it all
right oh no she took the bread off
myself
but I just take the top of the pizza
and a little salad which has basically
all the same toppings as the pizza yeah
but so do the toppings
the toppings of the pizza have the
toppings
a pizza salad
[Music]
the person just laughing so mad
and then it's actually really crunchy
and delicious
crunchy
yeah true you get the satisfaction of
eating a pizza but no maybe if you're
gluten intolerant
please
and now she's eating ah nothing's like
bread huh
isn't that [ __ ] up though how bread is
like that's because it's not the second
year
oh man your body eats bread and your
body goes the [ __ ] is that but it's so
good dude I love these famous people
that just like social media has really
exposed them to just be like the
lunatics they are and I'm not saying
Drew Barrymore is a lunatic but like
sometimes you I mean you saw the Drew
Barrymore show or whatever the [ __ ] that
was that interview show where she did I
mean that was just you know at what
point is enough is enough you know you
look at the Rock and [ __ ] you see the
rock [ __ ] um
he posted a a an Instagram reel the
other day and he was like never got to
hang out with my dad so I'm I wish I had
the relationship so I'm hanging out with
my the guy who plays my dad in [ __ ]
in the rock show on NBC dude and it was
like and then he played it over the
music was
one more time to dance with my father
again and they're just sauntering on
grass and it's like all good feel bad
but you doing
like I can't didn't get to hang out my
dad so much so it's great I get to hang
out my TV dad
he's younger than you
Dance With My Father Again
Luther Vandross
that song will make you [ __ ] CR dude
I [ __ ] whenever I would see [ __ ]
about my dad not my dad but dad's in
movies I cry and I was like one day I'll
get over that because of the I love my
my dad you know I love my mom too but
like something about like father-son
[ __ ] and now I was getting over it then
Calvin came dude
dance with my father again and now I'm
[ __ ] on the other end of it dude
[ __ ] I I'm like is Kevin Costner in
my eyeball asking Dennis Hopper where's
the girl because this shit's Water World
Dance With My Father Again
um
yeah forget it dude
I mean anyway
I'm gonna try that pizza I want pizza so
bad dude it's unfair how good pizza is
and ice cream is
it's on if I I would eat pizza and ice
cream every day and no [ __ ] and
maybe I should just do that until I die
for real
like why like you know do you are you
like me do you fi are you like should I
be hell because man because I wake up
sometimes my tummy hurts from the night
before and I'm like I shouldn't have ate
those [ __ ] burgers and [ __ ] and ice
cream and maybe I should eat like more
salads and you know I've been really a
[ __ ] train wreck eating because you
know it's like one addiction at a time
and like sugar be really tasting really
good but like I had to [ __ ] man maybe
I should just now that I got Calvin it's
like irresponsible but like maybe I
should just eat [ __ ] pizza and ice
cream and [ __ ] it's so good
it's so [ __ ] good I'm just gonna eat
pizza and ice cream every [ __ ] day
put the pizza on the ice cream just Drew
Barrymore it up and it's crunchy
oh God I'm so
[ __ ] here's another one the economics
behind quiet quitting and what we should
call it instead
oh
20-something engineer named zad Khan
sounds like a Batman villain with the
sound of a piano playing in a regime
style so this is on Tick Tock I recently
learned about this term called quiet
quitting where you're not outright
quitting your job or you're quitting the
idea of going above and beyond
you're still performing your duties but
no longer subscribing to hustle culture
mentality that the work is in your life
the reality is it's not and your worth
as a person is not defined by your labor
oh dude try telling that to a [ __ ]
man
that's how a lot of men get their
self-worth but okay quiet quitting in
other words it's not really about
quitting it's more like a philosophy for
doing the bare minimum at your job
that's how this country runs baby dude
you don't want your Amazon delivery guy
showing up like hi
gotta here you creep
you don't want some guy to you you
really want to bang tell her hello how's
dude you know how pissed off I get at
[ __ ] when I'm in Wells Fargo and
they're like and did you do anything fun
for the weekend and I'm like take this
paper
just tell me to sign the bank sigh of
the [ __ ] Nara
it's so annoying dude welcome to Wells
Fargo they asked me 70 different
questions I think they actually got hip
to it because I started complaining
about it a lot on stage I didn't put in
my last um two specials ago I was gonna
but I was doing it all over the country
about how annoying it was Wells Fargo
was [ __ ] when they were asking me
how's your how's your day how's your day
you do anything for the weekend yeah you
got a girl in your life just like what
the [ __ ] give me the [ __ ] let me put
this let me push this paper under this
glass and give me a small bottle of
water that's the size of a keychain and
I'm out
like dude
that's how this country runs I don't
want my [ __ ] guys going above and
beyond I don't want that [ __ ] I need a
bunch of people that don't want to be at
work throwing like my [ __ ] packages
at my door trying to Ricochet them off
with lamp posts and [ __ ]
the last thing I want is a friendly
[ __ ] when I'm trying to check
something out the last thing I want here
you go thank you here you go that's 5.95
thanks
bye
hey there how are you nope dude
I'm fine how much I see this they think
I'm the dick but it's like I'm rushing
about this [ __ ] dude don't smile at me
because I just think you want something
from me
in Japan there's a concept called
shokunin which refers to an artisan who
is deeply dedicated to their craft
always striving for perfection in what
they make
that's Japan
if I want that
I'll move to Tokyo dude
give me some half-assed American [ __ ]
dude I want my cars breaking the [ __ ]
down and people pissed off that they're
sitting behind glass
quiet quitting is the opposite of
shokunin
setting boundaries and simply completing
the tasks you're opposed to complete
within the time that you're paid to do
them [ __ ] yeah America no extra Frills
[ __ ] yeah dude when I go to my show I do
an hour or less of material and give it
my all baby and after that I'll do the
meet and greet I'm all smiles dude
because you know what I do love you and
life [ __ ] rips I do I love you and
I've been taking that CBD dude that pure
Spectrum CBD I've been taking that CBD
and it's keeping me all regulated and
nice my legs don't even move at night
anymore when I go to sleep I don't have
restless leg syndrome you want the
[ __ ] CBD click the link in the show
description you get 10 off if you use
code congrat congrats
but I'm even the [ __ ] out the second
I'm done with that meet angry because I
do secretly love you you guys when I say
oh thank you very much I appreciate all
the artwork you can even that weird
[ __ ] art you work that the guy made
of me in a Freddy Krueger thing that's
on the tour report I thank you for that
dude give me a bunch of stickers that
say life rips with the Freddy Krueger
design on it super weird I love you for
that though bro
couldn't exactly bring the Freddy glove
on the plane because they're knives but
I still love you bro but the second I'm
done dude the second I go into my car
I'm tired of [ __ ] dude
that's that
No Frills
you know
that's me not checking my emails you
know that's me not checking my emails
on the weekends that's me [ __ ] I'm tired
right now dude
yeah man we're back dude I had to take a
break dude I mean I I was starting to
talk about the lights and [ __ ] and the
and then I started feeling dizzy so
that's cool man am I just old
um and in the meantime ordered ordered
food because I'm disrespectful like that
but respectful because that's me dude um
let's do some Tinder and deserve it
scales
I love you guys and Peoria and Rockford
I'll see you soon Savannah Georgia and
Raleigh I'll see you soon chrisley.com
for tickets but let's do these here
deserve it scales God these are [ __ ]
there we go boy
uh to steal a cell phone in London
all right
see what this is all about
oh [ __ ] dude
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
my back
oh the kid is
is that a kid
a kid has got it wait hold on what the
[ __ ] is happening right now an adult
just so by the way the adult's so
insecurely [ __ ] tackled him look he's
like should I do it should I do it just
boot him into this [ __ ] thing so the
guys got him down the camera goes away
and then the kid comes by and just
starts choking why did the guy leave are
they a team is it Batman and Robin
what the [ __ ] this is so weird dude
why did they tap why did the guy like
like tag team it look at the people just
wondering about like oh nothing to see
your hands just let's go let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
the most British guy with the [ __ ]
British dog came by
foreign
and then the woman comes out what out do
you need what are you talking about
there's a dude that's
the guy stole a phone
why
what happened to the first guy that
booted him into the wall
he's just gone he's like did my part
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here I'll go
to a grocery store
and Sideshow Bob the guy
all these people are the most British
people of all time because there's like
dude the way the guy booted him
look at the Wake everyone should I I
don't know [ __ ] it boom into the thing
smashed him it is crazy he gets up and
lets the kid handle it the kid just
[ __ ] falls on him
my back my back my back my back
was that Trina my neck my back okay here
we go
um that was I mean you deserve it if you
steal a phone that is uh how did that do
boot he won't learn his lesson that way
here we go okay
um
here's another one
hold on
somebody caught him in line
let's watch this [ __ ]
oh
holy [ __ ] I'm not even gonna say the
n-word you [ __ ] black dude and then
he [ __ ] the guy just picks him up and
holy [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ] hilarious
The Voice dude I'm trying to catch me
bro are you serious bro I'm not even
gonna say the N word [ __ ] black guy
dude he just throws him into the
milkshake maker
and they start throwing fries at him
that guy handled dude
I mean I never seen somebody get more
handled than that I'm not gonna say the
n-word you [ __ ] black guy [ __ ] goes
okay
threw him up like it was one of the
burgers Jesus Christ dude that's
hilarious wow that kid so [ __ ] was
that uh big bully in home alone or
whatever no uh what's the [ __ ] movie
uh uh uh the Christmas story
so [ __ ] New York the way he pushed
him
bro
what [ __ ] black guy
dude the [ __ ] what
I'm not even gonna say the N word what
dude you know what that reminded me of
this [ __ ] dude when he goes what that
reminded me of this [ __ ] um
oh we don't have it oh you do everything
that one uh
what
dude [ __ ]
wow that was unbelievably thrown like a
sack of potatoes that must have heard so
bad dude wow dude
oh you're talking about I got a problem
I can see the n word you [ __ ] black
guy
So Long Island dude
oh wow trying to fight a wall what the
[ __ ] is this person doing here we go
trying to fight a wall that says what
could go wrong
we love it
oh [ __ ] that's a cartoon that girl
became a cartoon
oh one thing's for sure this girl has
the best parents
because the best parents dude she thinks
nothing could go wrong you know she's
like let me just get in this small
[ __ ] 6x6 room and launch off one of
the walls and the hopefully the
elevator's open boom
boom right there and Falls like the
Family Guy with her arm behind her back
I mean unbelievable this girl has the
best parents ever
wow
that [ __ ] she killed it
deserve it scale a [ __ ] 10. that
one's funny because she's probably okay
I hope that one's a 10 dude oh the one
they got when they when they threw the
guy when when he when
when she threw the guy or when the dude
throw the guy that's at 10 that was one
of the best deserved skills of all time
what
I'm gonna call you the n-word what
let me throw you into the [ __ ] malt
machine
uh anyway dude you guys I had a good
time with you
um thanks for uh listening to like And
subscribe Peoria I will be there
uh tomorrow or the next day or something
and then Rockford Illinois I'll be there
the next day and then Savannah and
Raleigh and Tempe and [ __ ] we got them
all coming up Dallas or not Dallas
Denver sorry and uh Boston we're having
a good time like And subscribe we love
you my babies keep it real
that's it for the YouTube episode but if
you want to catch the raw the uncut the
extra length episode you're going over
to our patreon patreon.com crystalia and
we also do other things like we have a
thing called review mode where we review
different things we have a podcast I'd
put an episode of a podcast up with
Kristen and a two of them I believe one
of them at least one of them uh and then
we also have an extra episode a month
that you can get offer six dollars a
month uh like And subscribe uh but also
subscribe to our patreon patreon.com
thank you very much
foreign
[Music]